Hello, Sarbjeet. Hi, Manu.
Yeah, uh, hey Manu, good to see you. Bye.
Hi, Crystal. Good morning.
Hey, Crystal, good morning.
Hello, good morning. Happy Friday.
Happy Friday.
Happy, happy Friday. How is it going, Crystal?
It's going well, been a little busy, but as well.
Same here. Have you met Manu and Sarbjeet yet?
I've met Manu, but not Sarbjeet.
Let me quickly introduce myself. Crystal, so I'll be the CX for your team. So earlier it was Justin, so I'm filling up Justin. It's been almost a decade I have been working with IT by design. Prior to this role, I have been a part of the service delivery team. So think of me as a part of your extended team in case if there is anything at all, Ayra, Manu, they are already there.
No.
Okay.
But if there is anything where we can help you out, we guys are just a text away.
Thank you.
It's a pleasure to meet you, Crystal.
Sameer.
Thank you, Ayra.
Okay, you're welcome, Sarbjeet. Let me quickly share my screen. So let me know once it's available so we can start this meeting. Thank you.
I can see your screen.
Okay, cool. Thank you, Crystal. So this is going to be for the month of May. This is actually our first monthly business review. Moving on to agenda items, that's pretty much the same. I haven't changed any. For check-in, this is for you, Crystal. How are things at this moment? Any
challenges, opportunities you want to share.
And.
I guess I can. So I know that we are waiting. Well, I'm working with our internal network security engineer to get access for John Matthew for the on-prem clients. It's been a challenge, if you will, because he's the only person on our.
network security team at the moment. So it's just been a challenge with us getting that set up for him and him providing support for our clients. I have pulled in another resource or member on my team to assist with that. So, but my intent is to have that set up before the end of next month.
so we can ensure he has the access that he needs. I've also had one of my engineers resign this week, so I've reached out to Andrea to see if we could get a level 3 engineer or resumes so that I can review them.
To get assistance with that, so...
Gotcha. Thank you. As for Andrea, she's out today until 29th. I did, she did tell me about the profiles that's pending on our end. So if you have urgent concerns, you can directly shout to me, Sarbjeet or Manu, so we can answer you because
Mhm.
Just gonna be out until Monday.
Okay, yeah, it's just I just need a few resumes to review. That's all.
Kip.
Alright, I believe Manu, you're already aware of this, right? And we're already working on the profiles. OK, perfect.
Yes.
Yes, she did mention that she will send the bill rate to me to review. So I don't know if that's something that you could obtain or anyone else.
Bill rate, right? Okay. Manu, are you aware of the bill rate for L3? Would you be able to help out on this?
Mhm.
Yes, do you have a job description, Crystal, for that?
And yes, I did send it to Andrea yesterday, but I can send it to you directly.
Yeah, please do that. And what I'll do is I will work with our talent acquisition team and then we can give you the bill rate once we see that. Yeah.
Okay.
Shukla.
Yes.
Okay, thank you, Manu. So, we'll wait for that, Crystal, for the job description, so Manu can work with our TA team, so we can send you the full rate.
Kam.
Thank you so much. Anything else before we move on?
OK.
That's it. That's it at the moment.
Okay. We appreciate you, Crystal, for being proactive for the access of John Matthew. That would help a lot, especially he's been handling a lot of L1 tickets lately, especially for on-prem access. So to help you out, we'll be waiting for his full access so he can work on a lot of
Agam.
Do you need a free makeup?
Yes.
I'm sorry.
Sorry, OK, so both of them are working for. Yes, because they have the driver.
Tickets to help you for it.
Perfect. Moving on to the highlights, Crystal. So I have two for you. John Matthew maintained 95% of attendance coverage for the month of May, reflecting strong reliability and consistent availability throughout the period. So we made sure that there's coverage for you guys.
Ohh.
Okay.
The.
What?
I'll make one.
I...
And also he continues to collaborate well with the rest of your team, to you, to Alexei, to John Wells for the dispatch. So he's been very good with communicating with you. I can see that as well. We've been improving a lot and we did receive
Mmh.
the first CSAT from you, and yeah, this is one of the action trackers that's been completed. So we appreciate that. We'll be sending out the July CSAT soon, so Sarbjeet is working on it. I'll make sure that there will be no duplicate, because before you mentioned, you've been receiving duplicate emails, right?
Yes.
Okay, I'll look into that Sarbjeet, and I will work on that. So should be no duplicate by next month. And also for the Barracuda training, John Matthew completed that already. I know you've been working on his Barracuda access lately, and I've heard that you would also require him to...
Okay.
Kip.
Play.
have the training on your end before he will have the access, right? Okay, so we'll wait for that. Until then, he won't be able to work on Barracuda tickets, right?
Mhm.
Right.
Okay, perfect. And the last item here should be the profile that you're asking for. So that's pending on our end, and we'll make sure to deliver.
And here's the performance analysis slide. We'll start off with the best practices or the KPIs that we recommend. You're already aware of this, the utilization target, the ticket resolution rate that we're already practicing in the CSAT.
So let's move on to utilization trend and analysis. So this slide shows you the performance of Matthew for the entire May.
If you can see here, the billable and the non-billable utilization. So if we're going to compare, it's still, the non-billable is still higher than the billable because of the dispatch. So for the overview,
OK, so I'm glad I need you to can.
OK, so anytime I want to print, I take it. No, it wasn't. I thought it was, and then I.
You.
The average.
How push beeps are.
Sorry, Kris. It's okay. Thank you, Crystal. Yeah, for the utilization average, I have excluded the total dispatch time. So if we're going to exclude that, his utilization average is 71%. That's 122 hours.
for the month of May. And for the total dispatch time, because he's just doing it 4 P.m. to 6 P.m., right? So that's 50 hours. He's been covering you guys for dispatch, 39%. Okay, so overall, his performance is good, as I can see it.
He's been working on a lot of L1 tickets, so that's billable, right? Because for the dispatch and other trainings, it's non-billable. So we need to focus on closing more tickets, so the billable target will be met. So the target is 80%.
And once we have the full access, we should be able to see improvement in this one, Crystal. Any questions for this slide?
I agree.
Yeah, no, no questions.
Okay, perfect.
So we can move on to ticket closure trend and analysis. The target is 80% and for ticket closure, it should be 8 to 10%. If you're going to average it, his resolution rate is pretty low. It's 45% and the total tickets.
that he worked on is 110 versus the close is 48. That's why it's averaging 45%. And it's not a bad thing right now because of the access. As long as he, because he already got access for the cloud, right? So that's why we're closing tickets already.
And once we got the full access for Barracuda for on-prem, hopefully this will increase, should be able to reach the target. But if you can see here at the bottom right, here's the top ticket categories that he's been working on. A lot of backup and storage, computer hardware.
Peter issues, that's pretty low for the month of May, but I've been seeing while I'm doing board reviews, he's been closing out Peter issues and email issues last few weeks. So yeah, any questions on this slide?
Noel.
Okay, thank you for that. Just to mention, because we have the holiday, May 25th, and he got one unplanned absence, so that's 18 hours. So that's why the numbers are low as well.
So we're working on that. I've seen changes lately. So by June, by next service call, we should be able to see the improvement.
Okay, customer satisfaction. So this is just for the month of May. We already discussed this, Crystal. So I've seen the June and I can see an improvement. So for me, we just received 2 because he's not been doing this survey status.
So, I believe you're picking the survey, right?
That template we have that on ConnectWise Management.
You asked whether if I'm picking.
Yeah, we're using that right on ECS, that engineers, the technicians.
Kip.
Okay, so I didn't understand your question.
I remember last time when you reached out to us, there's a competition for the CSAT, right? And in order for them, in order for them to get that, they need to select like a template in ConnectWise Management before closing it. Just like.
Yes.
A serving, yeah.
Well, I wouldn't necessarily say in order to get that, however, it will increase their chances of end users responding if they use that template.
Yeah, so I did tell him that and he's been using that already. So we've seen improvement with the CSAT. So we'll continue doing that and hopefully we'll see an increase of the numbers. Okay, you're welcome. Here we go, the Build It Live 2026. Thus BD, you mentioned that you're going to check.
No.
Yes.
Okay.
Yes, thank you.
on your end, did we receive any response? Do you have any participants or are you coming?
Yeah, no, I just, things have been so busy here. I haven't had an opportunity to even discuss or ask. So I believe he sent this to me the last time we discussed it.
Yeah, from the service tech slide.
And Ayra, let me share more details with Crystal. If you don't mind, you can stop the screen sharing. Let me bring in on the details. So Crystal, are you currently or your organization are they currently focusing on AI in terms of AI implementation? And are you using co-pilot?
Yeah.
Sure, thank you.
Okay, got it.
We are.
Claude or what's the current solutions which you are using?
What? Copilot.
Jarvis.
Mm-hmm.
In Athena.
Nice. So the reason why I was confirming these details because this is one of the great event for us. For the MSP community, I'm bringing it on the screen. These are the dates that's happening from August 3rd to August 5th. For these three days, the focus will be more on the managed intelligence where
We will be discussing about AI solutions, which we have already implemented. For example, we have the QPR bots, we have the bots who can take care of the dispatching, who can take care of even the basic L1 kind of stuff. 500 plus MSP leaders will be there, primarily the C-suite, the decisions maker will be there. So it's a great.
place for networking, 70 plus channel influencers. In terms of what I was discussing, I have, just for your quick reference, I have sent you the link in the chat window. After this call, I'll share you the complete agenda. Then talking about the speakers, who will be most of the MSPs, the large scale MSPs, the new charter, MSP Corp, Red HEM.
everyone will be there. And in terms of the venue, that's happening in New Jersey, Hyatt Regency. On the third day, we are taking our partners to New York Stock Exchange. That's an after our party where the team will be the Great Gatsby team. So we would love to see our partners specifically from your team. If you haven't been to
these events so far. And let me bring the agenda for you just to help you out more on the information. Just bear with me for a second.
Any questions so far in terms of, so these are the three days agenda. We, for our mastermind partners, those who are a part of our peer groups, our AA accelerator peer groups, we have a Pre day event. Then on August 3rd, the day starting at 8 o'clock, then we have the keynotes.
speaker from Kam and Sunny, then moving on to the rest of the speakers. That's hello, PSA. That will be the first main event. Then these are the breakout sessions, 4 breakout sessions which will be there, AI and future leadership, operations, growth, and sales. So anyone, whether it's for the leadership team, your HR team.
they can get benefit from this. And this is similar for the second day. We will have different breakout sessions on day two. And then last day, that's dedicated specifically for AI accelerator program. So we have the tools with the templates which are already built up, which you can utilize for your operational growth.
So this is a little bit about the event. And in order to make sure that you can bring more members, I have shared a complimentary code. That's BOGO1495. So you will be able to get free ticket when you will be registering yourself.
And you said free.
One complimentary ticket. So, yep. So let's say if you will be registering for yourself, you will be able to get one additional member over there. And for the hotel bookings, or if there is in terms of any logistic, if you need any support, I'm all there to help you out with the things.
One complimentary, okay.
What's that?
OK. Thank you.
Thank you. Any clarity questions where I could be, where I could help you out or anything, John?
No, I've sent the details to my team. So if they decide, because I know that we recently went to one, I don't know whether we're looking to participate in others. So I've forwarded that information.
Okay.
Thank you.
Sure. And after this call, I'll share you the complete agenda so that you can share it with your leadership team. And if there are any concerns, any queries, feel free to let me know. We can get on a separate call to discuss the things in detail.
Mm-hmm.
Sure. Thank you.
OK, thank you. Over to you, Ayra.
Okay, thank you, Sarbjeet. I'm going to share my screen again.
There you go, should be visible.
Okay, that's for the Build It Live slide. That's completed. For the ITBD by Design services, if you're interested in any of them, Crystal, just let us know.
Way forward. Actually, we will be having our first quarterly business review next month. I want to know if you're available July 24th, 1130 to 1230. So that's normally one hour.
Is that Central Eastern?
ESC.
Eastern, let's see, which will be 1030 to 1130 for meeting set on the 24th.
Of next month.
That is on a Friday. Typically, I have a standing meeting at the 11 hour time, so I wouldn't be able to.
No, yeah, so it'll actually conflict with an existing meeting that I have on Fridays.
Okay, any time, sir?
Is it recorded?
Anytime for, yeah, it's recorded.
So if you have any time slot, you can give it to me. So I'll arrange it. I'll also need to check with our CX and Andrea for their time availability.
Sure.
On the 24th is our monthly meeting. So would we be able to include that in our monthly meeting?
Yeah, I'm gonna convert that monthly meeting to QBR, so...
So it's normally one hour. If you want, we can do.
Um, 10 to 11 on your end.
Ten to 11.
I have a meeting at 10, 30, 11, and they're all standing meetings. Yes.
Yeah.
Pretty busy. It's okay. We can we can set up another time.
What about 9 to 10?
Nine to 10. Yeah, I'll check with Andrea and the CX team. They should be available, but I need to confirm it first. And then for now, let's park that, 9 to 10. I'll take it out of that. July 24th.
Okay.
Yes, 9980, yes.
Okay, thank you. So we're going to be reviewing the Q2 performance for Matthew. Plus, we have an upcoming holiday that's going to be on July 3rd. We spoke about this, so John and Matthew is not required, right? Because your office is closed. Perfect. Okay, and lastly, we will be sharing the profiles once it's available. So we'll wait for your email.
Noel.
That's correct.
for the job description and we should be able to provide you with the bill rate as soonest.
Sure.
Okay, open Q&A. Any questions from anyone?
Ohh.
None for me.
Sure. One thing from my end, Crystal. So apart from what we have already discussed in terms of number, are you able to get the value from the engineer? Is there anything where we should be focusing on in order to reach up to your expectations?
I think for the most part, John Matthew is doing pretty well. I've seen a few tickets where I think I've reached out to him about, let me just see.
Okay.
About a few tickets that I think he should have at least reach out to me to get more clarity. And typically he does, but one ticket in particular, I can't remember.
Let's see.
I know we can stop the screen sharing, that's OK.
Ohh.
Okay, sure.
I think I sent an email to both you and John Matthew about the ticket. Hold on really quick.
Okay.
Is it about the pending closure?
That, and...
I can't remember, to be honest with you.
No problem. We can search for that later on. You can always drop us an email or probably allow Ayra to reach out to you for the ticket details. So what happened? Is it like, is he not escalating it or reaching out too often?
Mhm.
No, it was. He responded to the ticket. And I wish I had the details.
What?
He responded to the user about...
I can't remember. But I did send him a message and I let him know, you know, for tickets like that to reach out to me to get more clarity.
If anything, and typically he does, it's just that one ticket I didn't see that he reached out.
But like I said, I have to go through our notes and chat to find that ticket to get more information on the details.
Mhm.
Okay, so as a general process, Crystal, what generally happens when an engineer is stuck anywhere in terms of technical support, Ayra is there to help the engineers out. In case if there is something which is process specific, we do inform them to reach out to the partners directly. So, Ayra, probably we can take it as an action item for ourselves.
Yes, yes.
Yes.
During your discussion with Matthew, probably we can ensure that he's following the right escalation path. And rest apart from this in terms of communication, in terms of notes in the ticket, is there anything?
Perfect. His notes are perfect. We use a standard note template and he follows that process, which I share with all of my team to use it to make it easier for others to pick up on details of the ticket along with dispatch to be able to reschedule tickets if it's needed. So
Nice, nice.
Bye.
His notes are perfect.
Nice, glad to hear that. And just one last piece before I let you go. I do see that we are also focusing on the end user sees that. How...
to know the pulse because at the end of the day, they are the ones who is paying the checks. So do we have some scheduled reports probably which you can share it with Ayra or like a monthly end user CSAT report out of 100, he was able to get 80, 90 positive, negative.
It.
So that Ayra would have more clarity.
And I think that's what she shared in the.
Yeah, I'm actually...
Okay. Oh, awesome. So I already have. Perfect. Awesome, awesome. Excuse me because this is my first time, so I just wanted to make sure I'll catch up with all the details. Perfect.
They're using crew, they're using crew, so I checked it out on this crew access, yeah.
Yeah.
Yes.
Mhm.
It's okay. Mhm.
Gaur.
Yeah, they have a very good CSAT tracking, so yeah.
Awesome, awesome.
Yes.
That's it from my end. Thank you so much. I'll hand it over to Manu.
Yeah, Kristen, if you can send the job description, please, maybe after this call, so that I can start working with the TA team, please.
Mhm.
Okay, resettled. Any questions, Crystal, before we drop off?
No questions. Thank you for your time.
Yes.
Okay, thank you so much, Javid, for joining this and see you next month. Happy Friday. Bye.
Thank you, Crystal. Have a great weekend. Bye bye.
Thank you.